[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa ya está lista conmigo
en el estudio àngel hablando no hoy
lunes dan y empezamos una semana más
aquí en directo américa le pregunto an y
entonces en qué consiste la reforma
eléctrica en mexico que rechazó la
cámara de diputados pero a lópez obrador
dijo que iba a presentar un plan en un
plan b sí señor muy buenos días pues el
plan del presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador llevaban meses
cocinándose y contradecía las reformas
anteriores que lo que hicieron fue
liberar el mercado eléctrico ahora en la
esencia de esta iniciativa nueva era que
la estatal comisión federal de
electricidad produjera como mínimo el 54
por ciento de la energía eléctrica del
país esto dejaba menos margen para
inversionistas privados también
pretendía que la regulación energética
pasara de organismos independientes a
estatales y tenía una parte que
nacionalizaba los recursos del litio de
hecho ese plan b del que usted habla
consiste en presentar un nuevo proyecto
incluyendo solamente el litio danny y
por qué ha sido tan polémico de este
este proyecto esa propuesta que pues ya
fue tumbada por la cámara diputados
el gobierno dice que la reforma
buscaba la independencia energética pero
los detractores de andrés manuel lópez
obrador y también los grupos
empresariales principalmente de eeuu
dicen que habría violado las
obligaciones contenidas en el acuerdo
comercial de ambos países con canadá
también que subirían los precios de la
electricidad y que se retrasarían los
planes de transición a energías más
limpias pues porque no habría suficiente
inversión en esta transición así es
miran y tenemos una noticia fresquita
que acaba de ocurrir y es que el
presidente ruso vladimir putin habló de
su economía que dijo en la economía
aceptó que realmente está afectada por
las acciones o todos los contras no
realmente todo lo contrario raúl mire le
voy a decir exactamente lo que dijo en
primer lugar advirtió que las sanciones
en contra de rusia lo que han hecho es
debilitar la economía occidental y
destacó que las medidas que han tomado
localmente hasta el momento pues han
estabilizado el precio del rublo que
había caído fuertemente frente al dólar
al inicio de la guerra y que espera
utilizar más ahora en todas las
transacciones local añadió que los
dólares están ingresando de nuevo a los
bancos rusos y que la inflación se está
estabilizando pero se le olvida
mencionar que se teme que en el último
mes ha subido alrededor del 20 por
ciento de los precios frente a hace un
año también recalcó putin que esto es
gracias a que el banco central ha hecho
recortes en las tasas de interés otro de
los aspectos que destacó es que el
empleo está abajo dice él y que el país
cuenta con un buen colchón
presupuestario para afrontar las
sanciones ya nosotros nos encanta y lo
más que a hablar de él y sus polémicas y
es protagonista así es porque twitter
trata de bloquear esta toma hostil que
catalogan de lo más que no de esta
plataforma claro y recordemos entonces
rápidamente que este magnate dijo que en
una única oferta pagaría 43 mil millones
de dólares para quedarse con el 100 por
ciento de la red social y acudió a una
oferta pública de adquisición hostil qué
quiere decir pues que es la iniciativa
propia nadie al interior de la junta
directiva se lo pidió ni se lo ha
aprobado aunque al comienzo se dijo que
lo estaban analizando finalmente la
empresa anunció que se defenderá a
través lo que se conoce raúl en el
mercado como poison pero esto es píldora
venenosa que es un dispositivo
financiero que ha sido utilizado durante
décadas para espantar a esos
pretendientes no deseados y su esencia
es inundar al mercado con acciones
nuevas o sea emitir más acciones para
que la posible adquisición llega tan
costosa que ya no sea atractiva twitter
dice que activaría este mecanismo cuando
un accionista tenga el 15 por ciento o
más y hoy y lo en más que tiene el 9 por
ciento bueno de ninguna cosa es lo que
él quiere digamos con proteger a su
totalidad pero otra cosa son las
posibilidades reales que él realmente
tiene para acceder a esta compra total
cuáles son además él dice tener un plan
b que no todavía no obrador sí señor
pero otro plan b y las puertas tampoco
están cerradas del todo de hecho esta
maniobra de la píldora venenosa raúl
también se ha utilizado en ocasiones
para elevar el precio de las empresas y
le voy a dar un ejemplo una de las
compras más grandes y prolongadas de
sillicon valley fue cuando en 2013 el
fabricante de software oracle quiso
comprar a su rival más pequeño que se
llama
por 5 mil 100 millones de dólares esta
última compañía a activó esta píldora
entre otras medidas y al final valió la
pena porque ahora que terminó
comprándola pero pagó más del doble
bueno pero ahí no hay negocio claro
solamente que ahí tampoco se jugaba
digamos con las libertades y la
capacidad de expresión de cada uno pues
ahora digamos que un tema completamente
diferente y que no peligraba la libertad
de expresión danny hablemos ahora de
china porque creció más de lo esperado
claro en el primer trimestre de 2022 el
producto interno bruto creció 4,8 por
ciento frente al trimestre del año
pasado ahora los rebrotes de 2019 y la
guerra en ucrania pues amenaza en esas
posibilidades de seguir creciendo
y
el conflicto geopolítico entre rusia y
ucrania condujo a una disminución en la
producción así como a un aumento de los
controles de exportación y afectará la
oferta mundial de productos básicos al
mismo tiempo a medida que los conflictos
geopolíticos generan sanciones y contra
sanciones entre algunos países se
afectan la eficiencia de las cadenas de
suministro globales y el transporte de
productos básicos además los costos de
transacción aumentan y eso eleva la
presión alcista sobre los precios bueno
y cómo están las cosas en china
finalizamos nuestro primer bloque de
economía danny gracias por toda la
información nos vemos más adelante con
más economía pasamos ahora a saber a
rosa pérez mateo en revista de prensa